una visita Relámpago 11 horas en total
pero suficiente para atraer la ira de
sus aliados europeos el viaje de
olabsols a China se produce Poco después
de la reelección de Pink como jefe del
partido comunista chino un régimen que
es denunciador regularmente por sus
abusos a los Derechos Humanos
especialmente contra La minoría
los Derechos Humanos son universales
esto se aplica a los derechos civiles y
las libertades económicas así como a los
derechos económicos sociales y
culturales y esto es especialmente
cierto para la protección de los
derechos de las minorías todos los
miembros de las Naciones Unidas se han
comprometido a ello la parte china se
congratula del evento la visita del
concierto se considera una señal de que
Beijing no está aislada para china a
Alemania Afirma así su independencia de
sus socios occidentales principalmente
de Washington pero para Berlín Beijing
sigue siendo sobre todo su
socioeconómico más importante o la
shorts no por casualidad con una
delegación de altos ejecutivos incluida
la de Volkswagen el gigante del
automóvil realiza el 40% de sus ventas
en chino las empresas alemanas dependen
en gran medida del mercado chino una
tendencia que se acentúa Alemania nunca
ha invertido tanto en China llegando a
los 10.000 millones de euros este año
esta polémica visita se produce en un
momento decreciente desconfianza hasta
china en occidente las dos naciones
volverán a reunirse dentro de 15 días en
Indonesia para la próxima Cumbre del g20